there's this quote from one of my
friends Alex homozy that says you don't
become Confident by shouting
affirmations in the mirror but by having
a stack of undeniable proof that you are
who you say you are outwork your
self-doubt yes nailed completely nailed
yes some of these motivational people
are here the funniest thing in the world
to me they'll go and say when you wake
up in the morning pound your chest look
at yourself in the mirror and do all
this [__] I hope it works what works
for me is that everyday resume the
things I know of accomplished the things
I know I've done real hard work the real
calluses on my mind the real calluses on
my hands you don't need to pound your
chest in the mirror anymore if you have
that